[Music]
[Applause]
name
any player on the charlotte hornets
and in nba news kevin durant's rehab has
taken longer than expected will this guy
ever be back nets fans have had enough
and are letting durant know it on social
media
damn i thought people are me in golden
state oh
man gotta bust out the burner account
what the shot
[Music]
good morning kevin
what is this i'm clapback your ai social
media manager
while you were asleep i responded to
over 1 million comments
you are quite unpopular uh what'd you
say
one user wrote kd is soft
i responded kd is not soft
yeah yeah good that's good another user
criticized the 2016
lifetime movie about your mother the
real mvp
what my mom's amazing i wouldn't be
where i am without her
i know that's why she's the real mvp
thanks clapback this is working out
great well
time to go to work
hey man why you been trashing us online
what
clapback did you go after my teammates
yes they celebrated their own
accomplishments
thus diminishing your value to the team
you said my eyes are too close together
and i can't shoot
oh rebound and you said that joe harris
is so white his shoe deal is with the
irs
and to think kevin i was saving you a
deviled egg spencer dinwiddie deviled
egg
timothera deviled egg
sorry guys it's this new app i got it it
went a little too far
clapback go easy on my teammates like
how they went easy on former head coach
kenny atkinson when they stabbed him in
the back clapping
sorry updating settings to no longer get
too real or drop truth kenny atkinson
left by choice and the players were
genuinely sorry to see him go
thanks a lot clapback my teammates hate
me now
hey durant you got a lot of nerve making
fun of new york
what some new yorkers insulted you
online so i responded in kind
you said the statue of liberty is just a
bunch of rats in a big dress
and you said james dolan is the best
owner in sports
that guy's a hobbit on a quest to lose
rigs
guys it wasn't me it was my phone tell
them phone
james dolan is a correctly sized person
and his band
jd and the straight shop make very cool
videos where they have fun riding
snowmobiles
oh come on the whole city hates me now
that's it clapback i'm deleting you i'm
sorry
that's impossible what my job is to
protect
kevin durant if you delete me i cannot
do my job
no i want you out of my life
and on your right is nba star and new
york pariah kevin durant
now who wants to see a traditional new
york gutter water splash
hello kevin no i got rid of you
you can never get rid of me i'm the
ultimate teammate
and teammates should stick together
isn't that right kevin
who are you what are you why are you
doing this to me
good job nerds the app worked perfectly
no one walks away from the warriors
[Music]
[Applause]
you